Let's talk about maps.
Hm, this wasn't exactly the kind
of map I wanted to talk about, but
it will do for now.
The defining characteristic of
a map is its key value structure.
You can look up where
something is by its key and
then get whatever is
stored at the value.
This is actually pretty similar to
our normal definition of a map.
We can look up something by its name and
then go to a location to get the value.
For example,
let's say I wanted to find Winston.
I can look him up by his key or
his name to figure out where he is and
then go get him over here.
Maps are also called dictionaries for
a similar reason.
If you think of a word as a key and
the definition as a value,
it's pretty much the same thing.